on aurait pu intituler la chronique
canada dans le monde là dessus prost
bonsoir soir patrice ou même justin
trudeau dans le monde parce qu'on ne
parlait que de ça c'était il y en a que
pour lui
absolument que pour lui on a dit son nom
des dizaines des centaines des milliers
de fois je pense sur les ondes
cette semaine ce soit aux états unis ici
en allemagne
en france on va commencer avec un petit
florilège du phénomène justin trudeau en
langue étrangère
28e 40e chrono qui dope programme
trudeau au partido les bras ou de justin
trudeau est lé leader parti libéral
justin trudeau c'est la chaux proximo
primaire ministre or on en a parlé en
france on l'a vu cette semaine
justin même justin ou justin où il ya
divergence sur les prononciations
effectivement si vous n'êtes pas l'uso
phone ou sinophone n'est pas grand
compris grand chose à ce qui vient de
passer alors en france beaucoup beaucoup
dans les médias mais ici sur le site de
france télévisions effectivement ou au
monde des images de la soirée électorale
on comprend d'ailleurs que la famille
trudeau la regarder en français cette
soirée électorale c'est vous ça ici pas
trier et on parle énormément de son père
mais aussi de sa mère et des rolling
stones écouter le canada va cesser ses
frappes contre des premières annonces
spectaculaires qui suit la victoire de
justin trudeau aux élections sa victoire
met fin à une décennie de pouvoir
conservateur sacré personnage à
l'ascension météorique houldizy trouve à
l'origine une star d'autant que joe
biden canadien ça ils vont se faire
concurrence il est beau les jeunes il
d'or s'afficher en famille d'où son
surnom le kennedy du canada nous sommes
en mars 77
quand maggie trudeau profite d'une d'un
concert des rolling stones à toronto
pour aller s'encanailler avec le groupe
d'abord en boîte de nuit puis lors d'une
virée à new york alors que keith
richards vient d'être arrêté avec 22
grammes d'héroïne dans sa chambre
d'hôtel
voilà des articles ou si pressé créé par
centaines par centaines énormément fait
une petite sélection des plus exotiques
celui-ci double page aux émirats arabes
unis
ici c'est en nouvelle zélande on parle
de son côté boxeur et il était moniteur
de planche à neige les articles partout
des éditoriaux voyant en mandarin
éditorial dans le monde en polonais ici
cette pleine page dans un journal
espagnol avec ce petit temps car je
t'aime papa le fameux je t'aime papa des
funérailles et le journaliste commence
en général juste devant juste notre
double déterminer son éloge funèbre et
largement t'aime papa
le journaliste espagnole qui commence
son article en pardonnant à peter
mansbridge de s'être trompé au moment
d'annoncer le gouvernement il a dit tu
peeters trudeau il s'est trompé
mais il s'est repris alors excuses de la
part du journaliste espagnol je vais au
royaume uni pour deux publications très
respectable guardium qui lui site
richard nixon richard nixon en 1972 qui
avait porté un toast à justin trudeau à
l'élection justin trudeau donc presque
plus de 40 ans avant et puis ça c'est le
site de la bbc respectable du mi6 qui se
pose une question un peu futile
est-ce que justin trudeau est le seul
chef de gouvernement ou d'état a apporté
un tatouage est bien la preuve par
l'image ou le monde barack obama
vladimir poutine c'est non pas de
tatouage on apprend que la première dame
britannique elle oui il en a un c'est
sur le talon droit
bon très bien impossible patrice de
finir cette chronique sans passer par la
chaîne edge bio aux états unis c'était
avant les élections ça c'était dimanche
soir 15 minutes vraiment savoureuse
petit extrait de john oliver jones et
vnx non
voilà on se laisse là dessus qu'est ce
qu'on ferait sans vous mon cher
allez merci beaucoup saluent